lands airline works with nfl.com their
draft analyst coho chat co-host of the
bench in Houston and Lance kind enough
to join us good morning Lance how are
you doing good how you doing Dan
I'm doing great I watched the with great
interest the mock draft when it was
revealed now can you tell me if you
think the Bengals should trade a pick or
will trade the pick the number one
overall pick well I don't think they
will trade the pick I think the shirt is
always going to be cased and I have to
know what the you know I have to know
what the package would look like see
here's the problem in my mock draft a
lot of times my first two microphones
would like to create some contingency
plans because drafts rarely go the way
people think people get so upset about
mock drafts and they're just they're
just an ability to work through at least
for me to work through some different
scenarios and so I decided well so Zach
Taylor was the coach that coach of the
Bengals was the coach of Justin Herbert
at the Senior Bowl so he had you know an
opportunity to spend some time with them
you've got you've had some rumblings
about Joe Perot maybe not wanting to be
a bangle and so I decided to and Miami
has all the draft capital in the world
so I decided to go with Miami Trading up
to one and let's let's explore that and
see what happens to the rest of the
draft board now Miami has plenty to make
this draft happen what it would look
like the trade that's kind of irrelevant
to me because there is enough over the
next two years draft capital wise to
make this happen would I do it I can
tell you this I think Joe burrow is a
lot better than Justin Herbert I think
Joe burrow is better than to a Tongo
below I do I think Joe burrow is a
generational quarterback I do not think
he's a generational quarterback I don't
throw that term around lightly people
Drew Brees is generational we happen to
be lucky enough to have Tom I think
you're drew I say drew is generational
but he's not even the best quarterback
in this generation he might be third
behind Peyton Manning and Tom Brady so I
don't think Joe borough is generational
with that said you really need a
quarterback but the Bengals are not a
quarterback away so if there was a
packaged and that was strong enough I
would absolutely listen now it would
have to be a very strong
package for me to be willing to move out
of joke girl but I would absolutely
listen I think you're foolish if you
just say we're gonna lock on and one
lock in on one guy unless you really do
believe that he is that special special
quarterback and maybe that's what
Cincinnati beliefs
where are your doubts with Joe burrow
well so my doubts and I know what they
are I watched him in the summer in the
summer I watched jobber oh I thought he
looked like a six-round or I watched all
the quarterbacks and I didn't you know I
just put him away put him to bed and I
went to the first I went to the game
that they played University of Texas and
I was like whoa this is a little
different joke borough than I remember
seeing from an accuracy standpoint he
was more accurate his placement was
better and as the season wore on I
continued to have that same you know
mindset uh we'll see the real Joe
Burrell pop up soon and it never
happened and about halfway through I
started buying into what my eyes were
telling me and as I got into the tape
and really studied the tape it's really
quite simple Joe Brady I think the move
of Justin Jefferson from the outside
receiver spot to slot number one was
huge Jamar chase becoming a big-time
prospect on the outside was huge but
maybe more importantly Joe Brady the the
the passing game coordinator he
basically helped to craft an offense
that didn't ask Joe burrow to throw a
ton of throws outside the numbers an
especially field side which is the long
side of the field that was something
that was really wide open in 2018 like
wide open in terms of their game plan
Joe Burrell was asked to throw a bunch
of those throws and he struggled and and
that was not something that he did well
so I isolated every throw he made
intermediate from 10 to 20 yards outside
the numbers every one of them and this
year he was 21 to 43 that's less than
50% five touchdowns and four
interceptions so I wouldn't looked at
all 43 of those throws I wanted to see
what all of them look like and Joe
throws with incredible timing and
accuracy but those are very very tight
windows when you don't have a big arm
and I think he has a slightly below
average arm by NFL standards and when he
threw field side which is that you know
across the field
those same throws you could see the nose
of the ball tail down it was an even
harder throw so I think managing those
throws dance staying away from those
throws is going to be the key I don't
think it's something that will sink him
as a prospect but I watched all the
throws from last year and all the throws
from this year this is the throw that he
struggles with the intermediate ball
outside the numbers that requires either
exquisite placement and timing or a big
arm you got to have one or the other
he's got one of them which is why I can
survive but you don't want to make a
living if you're if you're Zack Taylor
and Joe Burrell in Cincinnati you don't
want to make a living and having to
throw that throw given the circumstances
the situation in the United States have
just travel does this help her hurt to a
Tonga by law I think it hurts him teams
want to have their own medical staff be
able to do whatever needs to be done
that's why every medical staff goes to
the combine and then there's a second
combine done or for medical rechecks
teams want their own doctors to tell
them okay is there a long-term stability
issue with two Otunga below will give
give us an idea if there's future
durability or degenerative condition and
so I think that's where too is hurt the
video I saw the video he looks great
moving around sliding around
I think teams would love to be able to
put him through the paces with certain
turns and certain movements just a
double check and I think more
importantly they would really love to
get their medical staffs to have their
own staffs own opinion on his particular
injury slash recovery so I would
typically say that would hurt him I'm
still going to assume he's going third
and that Detroit will trade out of the
third pick and and and somebody else
will move into that spot that's what I'm
working off of but I also don't have
access to the medicals things are going
to have to feel really good about the
medicals to draft him with the third
pick you know what makes me nervous
though Lance is and we're talking to
Lance airline nfl.com their draft
analyst is we're seeing a small sample
size with some of these high draft picks
where you've seen one year dwayne
Haskins was great for one year
Tyler Murray for one year Baker Mayfield
well a little bit more than that
Joe burrow was great for one year I
don't know if Justin Herbert was ever
great for one year but consistent to of
was certainly great for one and a half
years maybe like it used to be you got a
chance to watch a quarterback develop
for two years maybe three years and I
don't know what Washington has with
Dwayne Haskins I don't even know if
Washington knows what they have with him
I'll you know Mitchell Chu Biscay you
know maybe the Giants found struck gold
and Daniel Jones who they could have
gotten later in the draft I feel like
but to try to assess that as a draft
analyst you're not seeing much so how
hard is that to assess who is real and
who's not like Jordan love
I watched him last year and I went wait
what am I supposed to be looking at here
and then somebody said well he didn't
have talent around him I'm like okay is
he a poor-man's mahomes like okay I
could just start hearing this stuff and
it's hard hard to really assess how good
somebody can be or will be yeah it is
oh you're right about that and I think
with Pat mahomes we actually had a
little bit more I had more take to get
around I'm gonna mistake my home was
wearing up the things that he did where
he would throw a platform and he did
some say cutler ish type of stuff which
today at one point was a really good NFL
quarterback but you're really defaulted
into so bad habit and I focused too much
on that as opposed to the things that he
could do and the things that he would be
able to be coached on the next level so
he was a big learning I Adam was a
second run a lot from from where I
missed on on the homes you have to say
where you missed that's the most
important thing Shaun Watson we had tape
on the Shaun Watson so often it pinky
stuff that we all did all the shot loss
and well guess what he was a winner we
saw him in high leverage situations
which were too risky never saw the nose
high leverage situations can and he
doesn't necessarily rise to the occasion
when they occur in the NFL I think
Blaine Haskins and miss you you have one
year wonder Joe Burrell is in that same
situation you can't tell me and I had an
executive told me this and he said I
said let me tell you got to get on board
he's a different guy
he's completely different and he is
different this year the last year this
executive said Lance you can't tell me I
have to make
nor the aching tape it's impossible I
know you don't tell somebody in NFL you
have to ignore the previous season
similarly you can't tell me only watch
2018 on for love and ignore 2019 you
can't do it understand the difficulties
that love face with all his turnover but
how you play is how you play and I think
the one year wonder stuff I think that
is a concern for some NFL teams
surrounding especially the quarterback
position because you haven't gone
through the different you know you
haven't experienced the different highs
lows when did when did playing Haskins
adversity in one year you're going to
face adversity not really not like
you're gonna face the NFL John Watson
faced some adversity so I think that's
something that that you make a really
good point they're seeing one year again
especially sometimes lesser competition
what's that telling me you know if I've
got more tape yeah I'm a picking you
more like I do it Tula
but I know it I've got what to it I'll
leave you with this
I know Trevor Lawrence is great for next
year Justin fields like who give me
another quarterback that we should keep
an eye on I have a I have a bet with
McLovin that Trevor Lawrence doesn't go
number one overall I mean did you get
odds on that no just a tough one just a
gut feeling just a gut feeling if he
doesn't want it it would probably happen
just in fields if he came out and really
those two are the top two that I know to
be just perfectly honest and I get right
and I'm so locked in on this year I
won't really get to next year's
sophomores who will be juniors if you
know what I mean because that's where
the that's what the class usually starts
as whoever last year sophomore class was
moving into the junior I can tell you
this in terms field says come to me
those are the two custom field versus
Trevor Lawrence once again we're going
to have three years of Lawrence plan a
very high level around high-level game
and we could have the potential to have
elite physical freight combined with
elite production
high level matchups and games that's
going to be hard for Justin fields to
navigate because no matter what Justin
field does I mean we've seen the forever
Lawrence can do in the big situations I
don't think he's flawless people were
over playing that a little bit Justin
I'm rather Trevor Lawrence has some
flaws right now but it won't be until I
really dig into the tape that I can give
a real strong analysis of you know how
he reads defenses makes decisions things
like that but I would tell you this I
like mclovin Thank You Lance great to
talk to you and we appreciate your time
that's a lens early nfl.com draft
analyst co-host of the bench in Houston